hey guys this is Dennis the founder
thank you and I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book in video game guru
and today we are doing a Game of Thrones
Season 3 recap of the and review of the
whole entire season we have a special
guest Kyle from a podcast of Ice and
Fire
thanks for having me guys thanks for for
being here you know and both of you guys
have read the books I have not so no
spoilers spoilers coming down oh yeah so
we just ended the season we just saw the
finale we saw the red wedding and then
we saw the episode afterwards but let's
take it back back to the beginning all
the way back all the way
yeah yeah so in the beginning like at
King's Landing we start off with with
Tyrion kind of outcasted even though he
kind of saved their asses epilim you
know at the Battle of Blackwater he's
kind of out casted like he's in like
this little room no one's going to talk
to him and stuff like that would you
guys think of that whole that whole
thing I thought it was a I liked it I
mean it really showed because before
this he was handed the King and he
really he had a nice room and everything
and he who seemed to be on top of it he
had control of everything and then all
of a sudden he wakes up in this dark
dank room and nobody even cares about
him nobody's around and it was really a
good contrast to the where he was in the
previous season yeah I liked how Tywin
who is a much bigger part of this season
and I loved his character how he didn't
visit his son at all even though his son
was messed up and and he you know had
saved them and saved at least some of
them and and Tyrion was like super hurt
and upset by that you would think he
would know his dad doesn't like him by
now he's paranoid I mean he's his sister
comes to visit me takes an axe to the
door you know and sister looks at him
like look if I wanted you dead he'd
already be dead already I think this
door would hold me I mean he's he was
just alone you know he thought everybody
had abandoned him I mean he saved the
day and he gets no thanks for it so I
mean he can't help but feel bad for the
guy
yeah I do love how Tywin we finally get
to see Tywin in King's Landing
just the power and control he has over
his son and daughter and not only that I
mean you know Geoffrey's the king but we
really know that it's Tywin is the real
king you see he's the one who's
controlling everything yeah he's got the
power he really is the man in charge Oh
feels like you know Joffrey's just as a
figurehead but we really find out this
season that that Tywin does have the
power which we certainly saw in the last
episode of the season oh yeah you're
gonna say that I think I mean this is
going too far but I think Charles dance
is Tywin Lannister I think he stole the
season in terms of just an actor's
performance like just his every scene he
was in was just awesome like everyday
conversation with his daughter with
Cersei with Tyrion just saying and with
his nephew just saying like of course
our grandson a nephew grandson knowing
how much power he actually has is really
impressive yeah he definitely was one of
my favorite characters for this season
and and kind of just any any scene that
had Tyrion Tywin and Cersei in it always
intrigued me and let you guys pick
Cersei fans I am I am I think she is
even though she's technically a bad
character or evil character I think
she's very sympathetic okay and Lena
Headey is such a good actress that I
think that comes across because from
what people have told me and you guys
can tell me you know better than I know
that in the books
apparently she isn't so sympathetic and
is not such a like I was gonna see a
comet because I think I mean we wouldn't
get this is an explorer but if you read
the books you do get eventually
point-of-view chapters on her and it's
like even in her head she's not
sympathetic you won't like when you're
inside of her point of view I'm like I
still don't really care about you least
I was just me enough cuz you know I
hated her even more guys are very
unlikable just absolutely crazy
character she is just off the wall I
don't think there's any sympathetic yes
surrounding that character and Lena
Headey has certainly brought that into
it I mean if that's a choice I'm not
from I'm not sure if she's read the
books but it's definitely something that
she's she's wanted to do with the
character and she's achieved that for
better or for worse right I think it's
for the better because you know you
don't want we are
we have one character that everyone
hates which is Joffrey you know we don't
need like all these characters we want
them to be more nuanced and have things
that we like about them things we don't
like about them and and with Cersei we
learn we do know that her life hasn't
been so easy and and she does have good
quality she does love her children even
even the monster yes even the monster
and so I don't know so do you guys like
her better
you kind of said for better for worse
you what about you I definitely like her
better
because I think like I said Lena such a
great job bringing a humanism to her
character not just like the Evil Queen
yeah I definitely like her better in the
series and I do in the books mm-hmm yeah
yeah I think my animosity animosity is
that she's so horrible in the books I
just wanna hate her so much and because
she's being a somewhat good person and
she has that sympathetic side that I'm
like oh god I don't want to feel good
for this woman I don't wanna I don't
want to think she has a nice bonus
she certainly brought that and and it's
interesting to watch I think it's a
better acting choice because you'll see
you'll see arcs and you can see that
instead of just a flat you know
character another wonderful addition to
the season is the Tyrells in King's
Landing
with you know Marjorie and and Joffrey's
upcoming wedding you know we get to see
all the politics and dynamics in play
Sansa is like a pawn to be used as the
north and then we get to see basically I
always call her grandma Tyrell played by
Diana ray I loved her character the
Queen of thorns is fantastic if there's
anybody who rivals Charles dance for
stealing a season it's probably her yeah
she actually wasn't in it enough no I
mean she outsmarts everybody like even I
loved the scene when she's talking to
Lord Varys you know and comes up to her
and he's like to kind of disarmed but he
kind of backs away and she's like all
come on come back and she just out it
even with Tywin maybe Tywin again
there's only equal yet all equal maybe
or only equal other than that she yeah
cuz she was like she said like hey
it's great to finally see someone that's
lived up to basically the hype because
she was disappointed in teary and he's
like oh I thought you were smart and
witty it's like you're really not that
smart he's getting accustomed to his new
job counting coins right yeah so I love
the addition of Tyrells and then
Marjorie as well as this kind of
manipulator she's she's one of the few
people that can actually manipulate
Joffrey mm-hmm she is absolutely
fantastic
I love Marjorie in this season she's a
character that doesn't get much screen
time in the books but you I think
everything they've done in this season
is certainly things that were just
happening behind the scenes in the book
and so I absolutely love them they're
they're fantastic she really knows what
she's doing and using her charm
yeah she's got all those low-cut dresses
and we're gonna dress but she's sexy and
smart yeah great combination she's
really showing how strong she can be and
she's also showing a side of not so much
out of her selfishness but her
selflessness about how making the people
love you is a good thing like not
necessarily because you want to be a
good person but because having them on
your side is better than having them
fear you hmm
and I'm curious if if her whole
reasoning for that is to sort of Trump
Joffrey or to actually bring Joffrey
into that fold and have the people like
him yeah I think I think she wants to do
it so she can manipulate him show him
like hey this is the way to think her
perspective on things is a lot different
than than Joffrey's or or basically the
Lannisters in general because they you
know with Tywin like he kind of believes
that with the power and the fear that
that their house can bring that that's
the best way to rule where Margaery
seems to have look it's not like we want
to do these things to be nice but if you
if you at least keep people somewhat
happy right they're easier to control
what I like about her so much compared
to Cersei is she doesn't you know she
doesn't really take crap like when stuff
goes wrong she embraces that and tries
to
make it work for her benefit we're
certainly kind of complains like Oh
Robert wasn't like nice to me sometimes
our marriage didn't work and what was me
whereas Marjorie actually liked look
this guy is crazy about Tamara I know
he's crazy but I'm gonna make this work
for my benefit not complain and try to
get something positive out of it I think
she has a better attitude toward royalty
if I can say then sir she does I think
she would make a better leader than Sir
she would one of my favorite scenes was
when Cersei tells the story of the house
of rain right too much don't ever call
me sister again yeah that was a great
scene because Margery was trying to pull
the same stuff that she does to Joffrey
to Cersei and Cersei is like I'm not
having any other no so yeah though that
was great in this season we also get
this battle between Baris and
Littlefinger we saw a lot in the first
couple seasons yeah but it was always
sort of an enigma what these two were
really after yeah and I think this
season really really showed us that vari
is sort of the peace and order inside of
things and and Littlefinger especially
in that climb speech yes this is a chaos
and sort of a yin and yang between these
two we're kind of really finally finding
out what these two are all about which
is pretty neat about this season welcome
sir I really liked when I think it was
Varis and I want to say it was a grandma
Tyra was talking about how they have
like at least a mutual enemy because
they don't want to see little fingers I
think I think the phrase I said was that
Littlefinger would rule over like a pile
of ashes like he would see the whole
kingdoms burn if he could become king
and ruler and they said we don't want
that to happen at least let's agree on
that one we don't want that yeah what's
interesting to you is because when Game
of Thrones first started in season one
you at first you think that that
Littlefinger is the good guy and you
think Varys is the bad guy but it's kind
of flipped around not that they're
either one of them are like super you
know good people but now you kind of see
that Varys is trying a little bit more
for like to keep things you know at
least semi peaceful yeah yeah it
certainly is and
yeah he is trying to keep it peaceful
and they've both they both got such an
evil side of them and it's hard to
believe he wants peace all the time
because what happens he gets he has a
guy kidnapped in a box yeah but that guy
did something I don't blame him ya know
he did something to him yeah
oh where where little finger I mean he
when he found out that Roz betrayed him
he served her up to Joffrey
yeah he knew what Joffrey was gonna do
and was it wasn't it wasn't nice
no really kind of a does it end justify
the means cuz I feel like a lot of the
viewers are starting to side with varis
cuz he does like the piece in order but
he's doing evil things just like little
fingers doing evil things but I don't
think little fingers gain in any friends
no or any fans excuse me no and uh I
don't know Roz like I liked Roz I was
sad to see her go especially because I
prefer her as the prostitute character
versus Shaye who's also the other
prostitute character who's Tyrians love
interest I don't know I just I just
can't I don't like her character I don't
like her storyline I just don't I wish
you would just go away
I mean she turns out like a you know
think full of diamonds could add a nice
mansion somewhere across the sea so a
nice proposal I'll be like yeah I'll
take it but no she's she stubborn
yeah the bag of diamonds come on yeah I
would have taken that and run yeah she's
still she's upset about the whole Tyrion
marrying Sansa thing which you know
Sansa is starting to at least in the
finale we see that she's starting to
accept it and I'm starting to understand
that that Tyrion is actually a good guy
and it's not so bad it's way better than
being married to Joffrey that's for sure
you know but what does she think is
gonna happen why is she holding on to
this belief that that Tyrion the the son
of the most powerful Lord in Westeros is
gonna divorce his wife and take her and
they're gonna run off and in a sense
what is she how to lose
delusional I don't know if I said a good
point said you complicate things while
you're here you complicate things
yeah I just I don't know what she's
thinking so I'd rather her just get out
of this guy yes make the switch and then
also another Lannister who's not at
King's Landing we get to see Jaime
Lannister with bran he's being taken you
know she's supposedly being escorted to
be exchanged for her Sansa and you know
a lot of stuff happens to him he gets
his hand cut off which changes basically
the kind of the fabric of who he is
because he is he's known to be an
excellent swordsman you know yeah and
now he has he's gotten that taken away
from ya if you a swordsman is his hand
you know you can't hold that sword what
what is he gonna do and it really it's a
wonderful arc that has this season and
easily one of the best of this season
and just to watch him start as that
arrogant Punk wisecracking guy in the
chains at the beginning of season 2 that
final scene when he walks into Circe's
room he's broken just a broken a
desperate man that he is at the end
yeah I'd say one of my favorite scenes
this season was when he explained why he
was so hurt about the kingslayer's name
and the explanation of to Brienne and in
that hot bath thing about basically why
he's so upset by it and why no one knows
the real truth I mean I thought that was
one of the I mean because of the acting
in the dialogue and all that stuff like
was that was that scene in the book at
all it was that the whole bath scene
wasn't look and in his speech and
everything and it's such a beautiful
moment they finally lets down his shield
he lets down his guard and he actually
connects with somebody yeah and he tells
the story and he admits things and it's
a really touching moment and I enjoyed
it I thought they did a fantastic job
with it mm-hmm yeah there's another
little thing in there too it's a little
small thing maybe not that important but
I like when there's a scene in the book
when he when Brian does actually step
into the bath with him or whatever
or no she sees him or he sees her and
like he does mention that he is a little
bit aroused a little bit like not like
he's like oh I'm falling forward but
like he does he like you know what maybe
you know because he's never really liked
any other woman besides his sister so I
was like you know what maybe this is not
that bad I really their relationship is
one of my favorites on this season it
was enjoyable to watch him to go they
have great chemistry yeah yeah yeah we
get to see the little Kingslayer the ex
yeah well and then we're gonna see next
season like basically his reunion with
Cersei and what happens now that he's
kind of he's a different person and how
she's gonna either accept or reject that
and and also his continued relationship
with Brienne mm-hmm yeah one of my mom
one of my favorite moments of the season
was between him and ran with the bear
pit the bear yeah when he selfless act
he's already on his way back to King's
Landing yeah he's off he's scot-free and
he just like no I can't do this and he
turns around he goes back just to save
somebody yeah and I found that to be
extremely touching I loved I loved that
the character growth he had his who else
does he save I don't think he's done
anything but murder people yeah I think
though he's the only person who really
cares about Cersei and Tyrion yeah I
know and that's kind of it he doesn't
even care about his kids no no and I
want to say to accredit to the show and
just the storytelling of george RR
martin and Benioff and Weiss who've done
the show is fans were kind of split a
little bit with the scene with Jaime and
Brienne when he was talking about how
the reason why he is the way he is some
people didn't forgive him well people on
Twitter were like that's just like
that's not good enough like he that
doesn't excuse him pushing the kid
everyone doesn't excuse him kill he
doesn't right but that's the point is
the one right of the Balkan that in the
series in general is like there's all
these people who do great good things
and bad things and and other than like
someone like Joffrey or maybe like
Walder Frey like there's there's not too
many people who are like a hundred
percent evil or 100 percent good so yeah
I I found his character development you
know one of the best things of this
season and and the whole question about
Redemption is will the viewers do they
think he's alright after that speech so
they side with him now or whatnot I
don't think it's exemplified any better
than with Theon's case
mmm-hmm just such a killed those boys
you get down Winterfell or whatever
happened there such a hated character
and then this entire season is just him
getting tortured yes
and if you don't side with Theon after
this season you're never gonna side with
yeah it's not even so much of signing
with him it's more of a just being
sympathetic and empathizing with him in
terms of like like KITT like you know
might as well just kill him you know
even someone who's done bad things like
he has he doesn't deserve that amount of
torture you know he you might as well
just kill him I mean it's extreme yeah
extreme what what what's going on with
him
you know very hard to watch I mean that
last year when Ramsay eating the sausage
and then talking about the guy's penis I
was like oh man that was rough I mean
even I was like oh yeah oh yeah it's
rough people think about images images
coming back but from what I heard none
of this isn't a book right is that is
that well true no the torturing scenes
well it happens off screen right but we
find out about it actually all the way
in book five yeah but uh how in detail
do they go do they just mention that he
was tortured or did they actually talk
about the specific well themes of
torture that we got to see losses
different things in the book than he
does in the show I'm around that Kyle
that's right because um I think it was
it was questionable in the book whether
or not he lost his man jr. so but yeah
in the show obviously there's no mention
whatsoever but yeah we see we run into
him because the events are starting to
right after Storm of Swords is the
fourth and the fifth book so something
we're jumping too far right after next
season it was meant to be one book but
he split it up to feast for crows and
then yeah so book four even though we're
only with season halfway through season
book three book four is supposed to be
happening at the same time as it is book
three so so Theon's actually not in book
three okay because all this is actually
happening to them
right but we don't run into him again
until five it's a long break so right
after storm of swords is when we Brian
he's already like so this won't spoiling
because you've seen the finale now so
when he says we meet him when he's
accepted that he's reek yes so that's
when we see him in book five he's like
my name is Regan he says all these other
kind of things yeah he's really we find
them as an already broken yeah it's
already broken
okay all right yeah so now let's go on
to Rob Robb and Catelyn or Akeno who
spent most of his time this season
having sex with tui he didn't spend
enough time fighting you know at least
in the show like they showed a lot of
stuff of like you know his grandfather's
funeral him talking with Talisa and just
like all that stuff and then you know
his eventual and his horrific heinous
end with the red wedding so yeah it was
one of those things that yeah I think
was shocking to a lot of people
especially because they set up all these
things like everyone's thinking he's
gonna come and and take revenge for Ned
he's gonna bring how stark back from you
know all this stuff and you know all
this planning you know like I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna do that and but at the
same time we saw a lot of mistakes on
his part in terms of you know pissing
off all his uh the groups of other
families that are behind him and
Karstark are sorry exactly yeah the
umbers disappeared snow all the embers
but yeah it's such a it's such a classic
fantasy moment like the eldest son will
pick up his the sword of his fallen
father and avenge him and everything
will be alright and George RR Martin's
it's like no it's not exactly how it's
going to work all right yeah exactly and
I think people who who who expect that
or or are just used to that like some of
them couldn't get over the red wedding
I've heard of people like that's it I'm
done with the show I can't watch it
anymore
I was so curious about that I think
everyone who's every reader was curious
how the fans would react to this and and
whether or not they would come back and
what I think I mean I think most people
did I mean I think I think when it comes
down to it because the unexpected
happens that's what people people want
to see people don't want to see the same
stuff you know I mean if you want to see
the same stuff you could you know
watched a lot of different other you
know shows you know fantasy or otherwise
through the show I mean Benny often
wife's were interviewed and Benioff was
talking about how you go see a
spider-man movie yeah and there's really
no danger like no spider-man's gonna
Parker's gonna survive I mean you know
comics even if he dies he's coming back
at some point he's not gonna stay down
so this show does something different I
think that's not something you find on
TV all the times the people are that
they're gonna stick with yeah I think
there's a small percentage of people who
are gonna write but at the but they
probably weren't I can't say they
weren't watching for the right reasons
but I don't know maybe they just don't
get what the show is
well they is doing they there are fans
of the happy endings and and for
rightfully so I mean they're uplifting
and they're they're fun and this show
isn't up with it's much more much more
of a grey just kind of week but but
realistic yeah way that the good guys
don't always win and things don't always
turn out Riven you don't always meet
your dad when you promised to meet him
at that way you know if you're if you're
honorable that doesn't mean that you're
gonna win you know the person that does
things the right way or the honorable
way that doesn't mean that you're you're
gonna come out victorious that's when
you see the characters you think the the
grittier ones the ones are gonna survive
I mean grano we don't I don't know the
end of the story ever the books not on
the end of the story so like you look at
a character like aria you'd think she
probably survived because she's not
about like the happy endings anymore
she's kind of gone well I mean she's had
the worst time out of you know I mean
she hasn't gotten tortured like Theon
but in terms of emotionally she's gotten
it the worst through a rough time I mean
she saw her her father get beheaded a
father who she admired and loved and
then who sees her brother have a pull
like Geoghan
body with the wolf head I mean and then
after she saw the wolf murdered right
yeah I don't
yeah I don't see that anyone else in
this story so far that's gotten worse
than she has and what she's had to deal
with yes she's had to grow up fast and
it's oh it's amazing just to watch her
go through it and but I love her I love
her character I mean I think next to
Tyrion I think she's like my second
favorite character I mean she's she has
a toughness to her and she's in you know
sometimes I'll I'm not bashing sanso but
I always like poke fun it's on so
because she just seems kind of naive
she's always waiting for her knight in
shining armor to come save even now you
know I mean maybe not after finding out
that Rob died but before that she was
still like Oh Loras I'm gonna marry
Loras and he's gonna take me away and
we're gonna live happily ever after
Aria like you know from the beginning
she kind of knew what the score was and
she's you know trying she's learning to
adapt I mean she physically she's not
capable yet of you know damaging you
know big groups of people finally you
know she killed you know that one guy
yeah you know I think I think mentally
she's there mentally she has the
capacity to do the things that that her
father and her brother were never able
to do nothing to say there's only was
one thing of the change on who she
killed from the book to the show and
that was the only thing I wish they
would have changed even though I don't
think they develop the characters you
know she goes to sleep saying all the
names she wants dead what she actually
gets to kill one of those people in that
scene so it's not like I suppose already
happened but if she kills one of the
like I think it's a tickler is that his
name it's one of them it's one of those
you know one of the guys was at
Harrenhal that was torching all the
people like with the rats and everything
she finds him in a bar she had jacked in
to kill him and right in this but she is
the one who kills it's it's the hounds
with her too and all that but she's the
one who kills him and I think there's a
little more personal this was still
great it was you know
different she's still with the hounds so
who knows how many more oh yeah she's
gonna kill along dad so it doesn't
matter yeah I like that relationship I
like the hound and Arya kind of like
Orient I win last season you know it's
just it's an interesting dynamic to do
two very different people on and before
she hooked up with the Hound you know
she was walking around with hot pie and
and re4 uh yeah that's the same as the
Hound those two I really like d'andrea
like his storyline I know in the books
people have told me that he's kind of
like a combination of a couple
characters or something like that
or a couple storylines are put in
together they just kind of changed his
story right yeah and they've they've
sort of morphed a character into him or
melded a character ate him that's that
took him on a different adventure but um
but but it's neat to see that journey
it's somebody we care about now whereas
Hedrick storm in the book is a character
we don't really care about very much so
so we have him going on the journey with
Stannis because he gets taken by
Melisandre yeah and we actually care
about what happens to him yeah unlike
this character in the book we don't
really know very much so it's a nice
journey we get to see that yeah I like
d'andrea I liked his relationship with
Arya I kind of hope that when they grew
older they would they would you know get
together and maybe rule or something he
does have Kings blood in him you know
and he's a strong character you know I
mean Ned's like oh okay this guy you
know when he was a just a blacksmith
like oh that you could tell that he was
he he had something about him and and
yeah with Stannis and Davos Stannis is
just kind of gone cuckoo you know he's
crazy cuckoo yeah I mean after he lost
that battle he's kind of like licking
his wounds and he just listens to
Melisandre about everything yeah it
makes me think that he truly believes
that if Melisandre was at the Battle of
Blackwater
he could have won because now he seems
so apologetic like anything you want
I'll do because you were right I should
have taken you I could have won this
battle right I don't know if that's
exactly what it's think he's thinking
but it certainly seems like it so now he
just wants to please her you know if I
see a question like da was like why are
you sticking with this guy like I
realized he saved your life he could
have killed you cut off your fingers and
gave you a title I get it but
this guy's crazy dude you should've went
on the boat with Gendron gotten out of
there - she's crazy
yeah I don't know why he stayed behind
no I would have just left with again
yeah I mean he's lost he doesn't have
any semblance of sanity left in him I
don't think yeah yeah because kendry
needs somebody to file out that boat so
he definitely should have gone well I
mean you know which way to be just
follow the five it's like it's not that
easy a lot of people are up in arms
about Stannis like he has a lot of fans
in the books and and I think he's he's
very different in the show know it seems
to be like he's hard and he's seen he's
strict and everything but he's I don't
know he's I guess it seems like it but
at the same time kind of an ass you know
just it's a weird character and I think
it's hard to get him to come across as
he was written and they're doing one
thing and it's it's pretty interesting
to see what they're doing yeah this
season we didn't really actually get
that much time no with his character
okay and then beyond the wall we have
Jon Snow
actually I just say one thing that I was
disappointed at and it's more of because
I'm a fan of Ciaran Hinds who they cast
to play mance rayder
that he wasn't in it more this season
like I was like oh ciarán hinds you know
he played Caesar in Rome you know and
I'm like okay he's a leader of the
wildlings he's gonna play a big part and
in the season he was in like three
scenes I think barely and as I yeah he
was not at all I'm assuming because of
who they cast that he's gonna be a
bigger part next season yeah is is that
I'm not spoiling it is he I think so
because you see in this season that it's
his plan he sends out these 50 wildlings
to go climb the wall and attack as a
black and open the gate and get them
through so he's probably just waiting
north of the wall at Castle black for
them to time to have their battle and
open and open the door I think that's
his plan it sounds like what he's doing
so he's just waiting waiting for that to
happen
yeah but I did like Jon Snow and Ygritte
I like their dynamic it's just a funny
thing yeah so I like their relationship
I yeah I thought you know it kind of
sucked that he left her high and dry and
she she wasn't too happy about what
something about three arrows in him so
you know I call it even I call that even
a beautiful love story but then he took
an arrow yes that was it was probably
the most touching love story out of the
whole season
I thought those two characters really
had a lot going on together and it was
Jon Snow's first and it was just a
beautiful thing the thing in the cave
making love in the cave but I think on
the show a lot of people complain about
the sex position everything in the six
on the show was so forced and it's about
power it's like this season we actually
got some sex it's actually about love
you know we got to see Rob with his girl
we got to see you know Jon hook up it
was like it was a love relationship it
wasn't about power or Theon having sex
with some [ __ ] about assault I'm not
assault wise and all that stuff you know
was actually like you know loved my
drinking his contortionist you up with
those ladies they're like oh there are
you oh yeah pots of him rumor got spread
what he's doing but back to Johnny grey
yeah it really is a beautiful thing and
we get to see even jealousy like or
elles jealous of them and there's this
real bond between the two that even the
wildlings see and to go down in a blaze
of glory like it did because John's
honor and staying true yeah it's tough
it's another one of those gray areas
where do you choose love or do you
choose honor right yeah and then you
know in the season finale we see Jon
Snow we don't know what kind of
condition he's in he makes it to Castle
black and that's kind of it we're like
he's gonna live and die or whatever and
then also beyond the wall we you know we
got a lot more of Samwell yes and his
storyline with Gilly and and him
learning that important fact of the
dragonglass being able to kill the White
Walkers yeah it was funny because we
kind of I don't know Sam was character
he would show up in episodes like for
like two or three minutes and then that
would be a and then you know and then we
wouldn't see him for a couple episodes
and then he come back but he had a lot
of stuff going on with him because a big
moment there was Craster's keep yeah and
that and the Nights Watch going crazy
and and and killing Mormont yeah that
was that was a huge moment and we get to
see all that so so Sam certainly went on
a wild adventure he killed he killed a
white Walker when we've seen big and he
was the one he was the very beginning of
season he's the first character we see
he's running through the snow the
blizzard and he comes across he comes
across that white or that white Walker
yeah at the very beginning so we
certainly go on a journey with him
because he's he's off on his own and
he's doing his own thing in the most
scariest place in Westeros and then also
we see Brandon who I have to admit this
season for me other than maybe towards
the end his storyline didn't really
intrigued me they kind of just checked
in on him a little bit kind of like
Danny last season they're like hey
what's bran up to this this this week
and like not very much and then they
left you know and then later towards the
end it end of the season we got to see
okay see his like power and where where
his role may lie for for the series you
know well he beat he meets his uh his
mentor sort of is Yoda Jojen and the
readings coming here they really mentor
is a column old man yeah oh yeah even
walks kind of slow yeah but he knows I
mean this read character we don't know
where he came from what's going on but
he certainly knows a lot about what the
again and he's a I'm gonna get my
magical terms mixed up here he said he's
a green seer right right yeah and bran
is a wrongs of war warg yes so whatever
that means like Jojen can see jodan can
see into the future in the past right
and i think he described
and so they've all got weird powers
going on so Jonah has taken his hand and
you light him on this journey right when
Brad took over Hodor is like who can do
that and he's like no one can do that
Oh like no one go inside of the human
use that animals no one can do a human
so brands like another level he's
another kind of mutant yeah this is like
it's like oh you wanna find an Anakin
yeah one man well how many medical
reigns do you have so it is certainly
it's a much more mystical sort of
journey than and then a lot of the
characters are on and it seems to be
everything centered around the wall like
everything north of the wall is so
magical like what's going on but uh yeah
so we get his journey from so alright
well speaking of magical let's talk
about Dani and her journey with a dragon
she starts off on the boat heading where
where exactly is she
where did she land in the far side of
the map yeah so she's not to Westeros
yet she knows somewhere else
he's in Essos which is the other con
okay okay and she starts off let's see
where did she start off in this one
beginning the season Jimbo warth right
yeah course okay so she takes off she
leaves course does she's a fantastic
over the Unseld yeah yeah yeah and yeah
and that that hurts her storyline this
is a lot more intriguing than last one
because last time it was like where are
my dragons you know was a lot of like
walking around in the hot desert and
then and then trying to find her dragons
and in this season where we get to see
more character development from her we
get to see that herb turning into the
leader and also kind of finding her
mission or her cause which is the the
freeing of slaves and and and all these
slaves joining her army and and fighting
for her because they want to not because
they have to they're not being paid to
and they're and they don't have to they
want to and she's turned into this kind
of Messiah like figure which is Clara
mysha mysha yeah mother yeah so I was
definitely very happy with where her
character went this season it should be
much more proactive this season last
season she was reactively
Dragons who's just trying to find in
this season she's like you know what I
don't like slavery I'm gonna do
something about this so I'm gonna free
these people and I need to get an army
and here's what I'm gonna do and it was
it's a much it's much more interesting
to watch someone when they're making
proactive decisions and I think we can
see through these scenes that her role
in this world or her ideals are changed
and it's not so much about getting the
Iron Throne now it's like wait I had
this whole town was I think there's like
a hundred thousand slaves like it's like
pouring out to me and now I'm
responsible for these people like I just
can't it's not just all about like going
over and reclaiming the throne from you
know Joffrey or something like her her
world he was changing constantly which i
think is they did a really good job of
this in the season showing that and we
certainly see her growing as a as a
negotiator as in her conversations he
people it's not just a show of strength
but her actually talking to
we have crassness who doesn't think she
understands high Valyrian the whole time
he's just playing that up the whole time
and find out that she she was just
playing the game and then she totally
turned it on him and she had it all
planned out and she was thinking it
through and then again later on with the
second son's and all the young Chi and
everything she really she's sort of
flexing her muscles and I could I could
see that actually being a little
divisive especially the the young Chi
part where she kind of treated that guy
like garbage and took all his gold and
everything it seemed very honorable but
she ends up winning at the end yeah this
season were also introduced to Barristan
Selmy again again yes again absolutely
but introduced to him on Daenerys side
yes Siri emerges and he saves her and he
joins her army which is such a powerful
powerful icon and I think I think Tywin
says it at the beginning of season two
he's like - Tyrion wasn't it why don't
why did you let him go yeah he's so
people care about him yeah but it wasn't
what antarians fault it was Joffrey's
well yeah but he sent Tywin had sent
Tyrion to King's Landing to watch over
Joffrey and make sure he didn't make any
dumb choice yeah it's hard to watch over
a job is that's a tough tab I don't
think Tywin completely understood how
Joffrey I think yeah I think he's
starting to understand now oh he is now
definitely not when he wasn't in King's
Landing ya know but now but now he knows
now he knows what's going on yeah and
then there's kind of a battle between
Jorah Mormont and Barristan Selmy like
in terms of like trying to get the ear
of Dan and I kind of being the the the
counselor to her by two fallen Knights
trying to reclaim their honor ever
basically and jours totally in love with
yeah it sure Joris jealous of any man
that comes ready that that one new woman
yeah then we got Daario naharis from the
second side who is who is just so
overtly going after in areas that jar is
just like that one bit but Danny seems
to be enjoying it yeah she seems to be
going going with the flow going with the
Daario so so yeah for season four one of
the things that I'm really looking
forward to is is Yara Theon sister you
know cuz at the end in end of this
season she told her her father Baylin
like I'm gonna go get him like he
doesn't care he's like he's written him
off he's like screw him he can't have
any kids anymore anyway so screw him
she's going after him so that's one of
the things that I want to see in next
season what kind of things are you guys
looking forward to you know without any
spoilers they're just like things that
you could speculate on based on what
we've seen this season mmm well I think
just what you just said I'm actually
really looking forward to see what you
are is up to what's going on with that
and what what's gonna happen between her
and the Bolton's and Ramsay up there
it's gonna be really intriguing
you know I'm looking forward to that as
well mm-hm I think I'm looking forward
to just because of the actors playing
I'm just Nick alive Kestrel Waldo and
sir you know Cersei uh Lena Headey just
getting together and just seeing what
their dynamics gonna be like now that he
is this broken guy and they've been
apart for so long and you know how
what's their relationship gonna look
like I'm excited to see what that's
gonna be next season yeah well they are
brother and sister
yeah so I I really I love this season
I still think season ones probably still
my favorite season but I did like this
season more than season two
well the season two is still great yeah
still great they're all great I'm just
saying on a personal level season one
three and then two and then you know
we'll see for season four because I
heard you know from you guys and other
people that that book three is the best
book of them all so hopefully next
season will deliver on them yeah we're
about halfway through so we still got
some wild wild rides left today yes good
yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be really
interesting and and I agree a season two
I think 100% agree everyone that it's
not the best season but for you you said
season one I think season one and season
three are kind of tied for me at the top
I'd have to re-watch both of them to
really determine which one I like more
but they both have the beautiful moments
yes I say beautiful I mean horrific yes
like Ned getting his head chopped off
and the red wedding yeah and just those
those two moments are so so epic then I
don't know how you're gonna top that and
I don't know which one I like more I'm
so sadistic but uh and both both wild
rides
I'd agree - I think Season one and three
about the same for me I think publishes
in threes my favorite is because you
think season one took a few episodes to
kind of find its footing and get to
write and I think now Benioff and Weiss
are in a pace and a rhythm now they're
like okay we know this is our show we
are gonna you know stick with Martin's
story but we can also kind of some of
our own things too are not afraid to go
to stray a little bit from the book
which i think is when the shows that
it's best when it doesn't try to copy it
exactly
mm-hmm so I think season three is my
favorite okay well what order were some
moments or things that happened in this
season that weren't in the books that
that you guys thought was a better
change or something that you're like wow
that's that's something that wasn't in
the books and it really surprised me and
it made me really happy
oh wow okay I gotta think of this book
knowledge but a few years season two
people mentioned that re and Tywin that
whole dynamic
not exist in the book yeah and that was
great you know something like that oh
yeah okay I guess I can go there so so
this season would be all the
conversations any conversation the tear
that Tywin was in with any other
characters that don't get because I mean
you don't get all the conversations that
we see with Tywin that are in the book
you know if you never get a point of
view chapter on Tywin so it's better
it's nice any countries that Tywin has
just at with anybody in this series is
probably one of my favorites yeah I'd
have to go with Marjorie mm-hmm
like I said before we don't really see
what Marjorie's doing she's kind of
playing behind the scenes but in the
show she really got the forefront of a
lot of a lot of scenes and I thought the
actress Natalie Dormer did a fantastic
job and just to watch her work just
watch the gears move and her calculating
this and manipulating that and doing
everything was just so much fun to watch
and you could see she was definitely her
grandmother's the two of them they had a
scene where they set Sansa down and the
two of them I mean it was all queen of
Sauron thorns in that but you can see
Marjorie wasn't missing a beat she's a
grandma what are you doing come on she
was just so much fun to watch and I mean
you hate Joffrey so much sexy lady comes
in and just starts moving him around
like he's got this chest yes and it's
just so enjoyable I think that's my
favorite part of this season that we
didn't actually see in the books nice to
be fair to say like some of the stuff
with Tywin his conversations are in the
book but not he's given way more and I
think to do in this series just cuz
Charles Janis is just so awesome I
didn't give it more to do so outside I
appreciate it
alright cool alright guys so that's our
season three of Game of Thrones review
and recap yeah before before we go and
you know make sure you subscribe to our
new think hero Channel that's a think
hero Pro I'll post a link here we're
gonna put all the new reviews all the
new videos a lot of different stuff it's
all gonna be on on this channel so the
old think hero TV channel like has all
the archives of all our other reviews
and stuff like that but everything new
is going to be
so yeah you can also false on Twitter
mine is at Fink here oh uh what's your
Twitter I'm at Griffin de and yours I'm
at mad canard like the duck okay and
yeah then check out our Facebook page
that's a facebook.com slash thing
Carroll fans and yeah just put poster
comments below on on this video and let
us know what you think and any questions
you may have and maybe what other type
of videos you want us to talk about
certain things or anything like that
Game of Thrones or not alright see you
guys later
you